Justina starts off this hour in Atlanta
Georgia hi Justina how are you I'm doing
well how are you doing sir
better than I deserve what's up okay my
husband lost his job a few months ago
and last year I had a baby so he
expanded on our car there were a few
months a couple three months behind on
that car I was just wondering should we
just go back to diller and give it to
him or what should I do in this
situation I try to pay a little bit
because I don't have the amount to pay
the whole car the last government what
did your husband used to make 75 and
he's been unemployed for how long he has
a job but it's not even paying close to
what he just got a job a couple months
ago he was off he was a September into
September he got one like in the middle
of like October so whatever she make now
it's about 30 but not even a lot at all
are you working outside the home I now I
just started working and I'm getting
about 400 I just started making about
400 a week and what do you owe on the
car like 14 something $14,000 okay and
what is your monthly payment it was like
four sixty something a month
good lord you heard you had bad credit
didn't you yeah and we had another car
and we held a little bit on it and they
sold it and it wasn't it worth amount
that we are like it was worth less than
how much we owed so I got rolled into
what we were paying oh but I don't want
to make that mistake again I just want
to see I kind of want to get it off my
plate right now yeah that would be nice
but you don't really have that as an
option you signed up for big girl stuff
which is a car pack so if you take it
back to the dealer that's called a
repossession all right and what they're
going to do in a repossession whether
it's voluntary or otherwise is they're
going to sell the car on a repo lot
which means it's not going to bring very
much
and they're going to come to you for the
difference and when you don't pay it
they're going to sue you for that
difference that's what the difference is
called a deficit and so what do you
think the car is worth do you have any
idea um maybe 10 maybe okay then maybe
they sell it for seven instead of ten on
a repo lot online they come after you
for the seven difference if you owe
fourteen do you see what I'm talking
about yes and so you're better off to
try to figure out a way to get the car
sold and keep it in the meantime however
three months behind puts you on the repo
list so there they're out with a no tow
truck looking for this car
um who do you owe this money to uh Wells
Fargo oh lordy hey boy you signed up for
it didn't you I'm and the car payment is
460 and and you're three payments behind
so you need like 1500 bucks yeah Wow
your husband's new job is paying how
much it's paying thirty thousand and
he's working forty 18 he's working forty
hours a week
about okay is he working at night he's
like into the day and it's like good day
at night and he comes back around
evening evening time so he's every day
five days a week yeah okay and so as of
today he's delivering pizza starting
when he gets home and every weekend
which the good news with that is you can
make about a fifteen hundred a month
delivering pizza and by the way you've
got a car to do that with and to get you
can get caught up in about a month I
don't want you to have to do that for
long but I want you get caught up so
they don't take the car because if they
take the car it finishes up what would
little was left of your credit pretty
much destroys it and you lose control of
the situation because they're going to
come after you for that difference I
would much rather you get caught up and
then start working to pay the car down
and get it sold and then you sell it for
a lot more than they'll sell it for and
so the amount of hole that you're in is
a lot less is that logical to you yes
sir should I try to pay maybe some a lot
of pain
don't thing they won't take it you need
to be on the phone you need to be on the
phone talking to them though okay and if
you can work out any kind of a plan with
them while your husband is delivering
pizza like crazy to start sending them
500 bucks here and 500 bucks there I
mean if you send them 500 bucks every
two weeks for the next next six weeks
that that catches you up they'll do that
plan okay but they're not going to sit
there and do nothing if you're doing
nothing they'll come after the car okay
but if you'll talk to him and get on the
phone and say alright he's got a job
delivering pizzas just gotten a new job
I've gotten a new job we can pay you you
know one payment every two weeks until
we're current and or something like that
I don't know if you can or not you have
to do your budget and work that out I
don't know what your other point out of
Iran situation too so we don't have to
pay that right now I'm trying so here's
your priorities food and water and
lights and shelter our first
transportation is next so before you're
paying some student loan or some credit
card or some other bill that you've got
laying around you're catching this car
up okay does this is going to cost you
like four or five thousand bucks extra
if you do this wrong and you don't have
that room to wiggle does that make sense
I either okay have you ever heard of our
class called Financial Peace University
have you guys could have you been
through the class not yet you're in
desperate need of some financial peace
aren't you kiddo yes fire my darling I'm
gonna put you through the class if you
and your husband will attend he's going
to miss some nights because he's going
to be delivering pizza yeah all right
yeah if you'll promise me you guys will
roll up your sleeves and bust on this
I'll show you how to get through it it's
what we do you hold on and I'll have
Kelly pick up we'll get you signed up
for the class but I've been where you
are it's scary it's scary to walk out
the driveway and wonder if your car is
going to be there in the morning I've
had that feeling and I've had the
feeling wondering when I get home
tonight if the lights are going to turn
on when I turn them on it takes your
breath away it puts a different kind of
stress than just oh I owe some money
that's one level of stress but when the
basics like that are getting ready
you're getting ready getting kneecapped
you know on your basics your
transportation and stuff like that I'll
tell you me when you get repo'd it feels
like somebody stole your car it
activates the same part of your emotions
for those of you have never been through
it it's horrid it's a horrible thing to
go through what she's facing and how
scared you get I mean you got little
kids to feed and you're trying to do
grown-up stuff and we're running around
here and you know we're trying to find a
you know got a place to live with no
rent so we can catch up and get a job
making half of what I was making and
that's scary that's legitimately scary
the good news is this is not permanent
this too shall pass as long as you work
a system you work a plan to fix the
career and to you know stay out of the
stupid zone where you don't end up with
four hundred and sixty dollar car
payments on a fourteen thousand dollar
car
Wow is that mathematical suicide so that
is something she needs to get rid of but
let's not get rid of in the wrong way
because it sets us back on our heels
we'll never catch up this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]